there we go
see most people forgot about the rubik's
cube back in the 80s so it had its
heyday and then disappeared the
mathematicians remained obsessed with it
they wanted to find out the number of
moves it would take to solve the most
difficult combination
people probably are aware that there is
some maths involved in rubik's cube and
the group is the number of different
combinations that there are on the
rubik's cube it's the all the different
ways that you can scramble up a cube
other things do have permutations in
symmetry but there's just something nice
and tactile and then
you can you can grab it and you can see
the
everything as it happens
and this number would be called god's
number if you had perfect knowledge of
how to do the rubik's cube you would be
able to solve the most difficult
position
in
its perfect most efficient algorithm
they managed to work out that it was
less than 30
and over the years they started to
whittle this down closer and closer
no matter how much you scramble up a
rubik's cube you can solve it in 20 or
fewer twists
it's called god's number because you'd
have to be some kind of omniscient being
to work out those 20 moves it's just
it's so difficult to calculate what
those moves are
i mean i couldn't look at a cube and say
oh i need to do these 12 moves or
whatever but there are people who can so
they do rubik's cube solving
competitions and they have obviously
speed challenges and so you can solve it
the fastest but one of the other things
that they do is a kind of efficient
solve and the competition there is look
at a rubik's cube and then just write
down a list of moves that will solve it
which i think is probably more
impressive than people who can solve it
really quickly
it was called the super flip
now the super flip is essentially
completely solved
except each edge position
was flipped over
if you take one of those pieces off and
turn it around
you get a whole new universe you can't
get back to the solved rubik's cube if
you do that
4.3 times 10 to the 19. it's a massive
number though it's a massive number of
combinations it's 43 quintillion 252
quadrillion
trillion 274 billion 489
million 856
000.
it's just it's a mind-numbing number of
possible arrangements
so this was a big craze in the 1980s big
craze
in the 1880s exactly 100 years earlier
there was a similar puzzle that was also
a big craze
they had their code that checked the
reduced number of cases they ran on the
google servers and they did they
exhaustively checked and we know now for
a fact that god's number is 20. every
rubrics puzzle can be solved in 20 or
fewer moves
you might think well how do we know how
do we know that
did we just check all 43.25 billion
billion different ways of solving it and
we effectively did that
and there are 12 factorial ways to
arrange the edges